[MUSIC PLAYING]
So the brilliant
thinker, Geoffrey Miller,
has an amazing book
called The Mating Mind.
And basically, it
stipulates that the origins
of human intelligence,
that human creativity,
the amazing functional creative
output that human beings are
capable of is rooted
merely in the fact
that our brain is
a sexual ornament.
Our brain is the human version
of the peacock feather.
It's a way of capturing
and controlling
the attention of
potential mates so
that we can replicate our genes.
The evolutionary origins of our
immense capacity for invention
are stemmed in the
fact that we are
wired to procreate
and to mutate.
Now what's really interesting
is that with the advent
of human culture,
we've graduated
from spreading our genes to
spreading our means, which
are new replicators,
units of information that
need to be seeded
out into the world.
So today, we continue to
employ these ancient primordial
capacities for discourse
and oratory and ecstatic
articulation and
ecstatic vocalization.
Our charm, our peacock
feather continues to be used.
But it's like we're hacking
these ancient capacities
and now using them to
capture and control attention
to spread our means
instead of our genes.
Celebrity, or being known
really, in any capacity,
merely means you're
mating your means well.
You're the chief of that tribe.
And I just think that's
astonishingly fascinating.
It explains a lot.
[MUSIC PLAYING]